to be against lynching mob when they
grabbed black people out of police
custody to to lynch them so the very
fact that she's the first black person
to ever be charged even tried with this
when here has been calling gross
miscarriage of justice and a perversion
of justice was facing one two four years
her sentence 90 days 18 days credit
served and three years of probation
members of the black lives matter
community in Los Angeles they're also
both action to this to the sentence we
heard some people know that partial
victory yes it's definitely hard to
figure out we're happy that you can get
in for years we know that was something
that I'm gonna did the fact that they
started with probation but she still has
had to serve 90 days with that we want
to definitely appeal this but we know
that of this over 100,000 signatures on
petitions
those are all big things I've got to
make the judge recognize
it's not an option yeah and so we're
happy that you got the 90 days but we
still believe that that's it because of
that time sir and she should've been
able to leave today so we're still gonna
fight to make sure she can get out here
all morning from all walks of life very
different coalition's all chanting free
Jasmine Richards what they see carried
out here is as I said earlier a gross
miscarriage of justice the very fact
that she was charged with something that
up until very recently had been called
lynching Kara and she is a black woman I
just pictured a comment on what many
people have called the absurdity of that
it is absolutely absurd one has to
recall that the purpose of lynching was
not only to punish the offender usually
for the crime of daring to resist
oppression but it was also to warn
communities away from standing up for
their own rights and their own humanity
if the bodies were left swinging for a
reason and that was to impress political
personal freedom this is what happened
today
today that this activist was prosecuted
under this absurd not an absurd law
below it's not absurd some background on
Jasmine Richards the 28 year old active
in the community challenging of the
people that she was a target members of
the political
this country has a legacy of targeting
he's not going on right now today with
Locke we definitely think so we think
that uh you know Jasmine who was when
she was arrested on she wasn't arrested
on the day it happened but she was
picked up a couple of days later but we
understand that during the time when the
so-called riot in the so called the
lynching took place actually they've
been focused on her the whole time like
they're actually at least the car is
there before I had a peace march
beforehand so the police were there the
whole time there were helicopters
overhead and so there was definitely an
antagonism antagonistic attitude towards
jasmine this she's been very outspoken
about Kendrick conveyed was killed
killed here in Pasadena and so because
of that they saw her as a threat
Schmidt date of course was unarmed and
so you know it's just she had been out
there and she's been very vocal when she
had bearing been very militant she's
she's so inspirational she could talk to
all different you know sectors of
society she could go to the universities
and reach the students and the
professor's she can go to the community
to the to the hood if you will and talk
to people and get people to move and I
think they saw it they see her as a
threat
protests or march or anything to become
so she's an amazing young woman and I'm
proud to stand up for her and with her
her hey free Jasmine I just want to say
one more thing for anyone who is
unfamiliar with the story of Jasmine
Richards were out here today where she
has just been sentenced in Pasadena we
did a video earlier on aj+ folks back in
San Francisco will link it in the
comments right now but I heard something
and that is the prosecutor in the
courtroom compared black lives matter to
the KKK yeah during their closing
arguments you she was saying that what
happened was no different than what they
paid what she did was no different with
the KKK did right and so it's this idea
of trying to malign and you know like
the word terrorist was use a couple
times a lot of different things to make
black lives matter to look like it's
just you know this anti human race and
so that's what I think the possible try
to do it worked for a lot of the jurors
but actually one juror juror number six
came back and said even though he made
one and actually got her to be guilty he
regrets that and he wanted to have the
Lisa - and so he understood what he did
was problematic and so it was good to
hear that he wasn't what did you have
enough that we don't want other things
on this case on when the conviction came
down one week ago there was a lot of
criticism
to the fact that none of her peers on
the jury were african-american despite
the fact that 13% of Pasadena is black
not one lecturer was serving on that
jury is that problematic in your eyes
it's always problematic it's really easy
in cases like this it seems to exclude
blacks from serving on juries and yet it
doesn't seem to be so easy to exclude
white it reminds me really of the
Trump's comment about his judge being
mexican-american means somehow race
makes you unable to do the job and judge
citizen but it whites are dimmed you
know from that so there's really really
problematic message to sing and this was
an unjust prosecution and unjust
conviction absolutely it will be will
not stop
Russian and black lives matter
to make sure that everybody knows that
Jackie lacy who's the District Attorney
of the County of Los Angeles had the
power to intervene in this she could
have came in and said no time she gonna
say we're not gonna bring this to trial
so she didn't do that so we want to make
people know right now she's running in
the pose right so today she's on the
ballot unopposed but we're not gonna sit
back and we demand that she intervenes
or we're gonna give you about there to
make sure that no one votes for coming
come in November because right now she
has nobody just joining us I guess if
she wins today she might actually meet
at this tourney right yeah there's no so
we still if you haven't voted yet you
know and you're now in Los Angeles
County go out there and you know but no
state being California's primary there
definitely hasn't been lost upon the
folks here they're saying exercising
their right to democracy professor James
professor Michael thank you so much
members of a black lives matter la as
well as the professors in the area thank
you so much for talking to us
the audience tuning in right now we're
in Pasadena California which is in the
greater luck a lot of beeping up support
right there Pasadena California and the
Greater Los Angeles County where black
lives matter activist Jasmine Richards
has just received her sentence of 90
days in jail or 18 days credit that has
already been served she had been
convicted of a charge formerly known or
up until recently called felony lynching
walk that was the law that was meant to
protect people's put on the books in the
1930s meant to protect black people who
were yanked out of police custody by
white lynching mobs who of course for
then proceeded to hang them beat them
burn them everything so the very fact
that this charge was brought against her
for allegedly attempting to pull a girl
out of police custody back in August
folks here called absurd a perversion of
justice and disgustingly ironic the
sentence just came down folks here are
calling it a partial victory of course
they believe she deserves no tale times
get 90 days of jail time 18 days already
served and 3 years of probation but
they're hoping for is that it will
ultimately be appealed and reversed if
you guys want to get a sense of the
scene
I'll just have shadi who's with me right
now shadowing me just walk around to
show you I'm gonna get in the street up
on email that just may lock everything
okay on the left side there are hundreds
of people from all walks of life more
than two and a half hours all morning
long chanting free Jasmine black lives
matter
haven't gone anywhere
Jasmine's definitely jasmine
but what we're out here doing is bigger
than that her heart what took place in
her car when she was a damn example
opposition to do so is much bigger than
just us a free jazz
all morning they've been saying that
black life need to be treated with
respect and with dignity and that is so
often not the case when it comes to the
police including the black concertina
police we just want to walk a little bit
more I know that your serial so I may
where this is my husband
tell us who we're gonna talk to yeah
yeah somebody you're out here you
obviously in solidarity what is your
what brought you back well I've been
working in the community around issues
for decades and I've been in solidarity
and Ally chick with black lives matter
and actually I ended up Co organizing a
trip with a treat with doubles need to
take black lives matter activists to
Palestine and I became close with which
these colors so become a dear friend of
mine she's co-founder of black lives
matter a hardcore organizer here around
prison abolition she's been doing that
for decades this organization dignity in
power now is based in Los Angeles is one
that she found it as well so this is
Patrice's life's work and she's out here
today and hopefully you get a tooth done
ok cool - we're live on AJ I'm gonna say
this this is a partial victory and our
current political climate we would have
seen Jasmine Richard get the difference
between prison time in jail time jail
time means under a year person time
means going to state prison in state
prison Jasmine did not receive that she
could 3 30 90 days of jail time is not
what we wanted we wanted her to be
released today she should have been
but with Matt it is important to say
that it's because we were able to gather
eighty thousand signatures get letters
from across the country bring out
hundreds of people that the judge
herself
what's clear that Jasmine did not
deserve six months jail time which is
what the prosecution another victory
that I will say it's Jasmine organizes
at the part that word is the
headquarters were black
and their truck the prosecution was
saying they wanted her to stay away from
there
order you stay away order obviously
defense rebutted that and the judge said
actually Jasmine you are allowed to go
back that Park and she broke down in
tears because that's where she has both
loved and lived and played and worked
with her community so to take that from
her is like taking the spirit of BLM
Pasadena's way for those who are
unfamiliar and don't want a husband up
the stairs back on the case
can you explain what exactly she was
accused of and also what is the
significance of pulling your people away
from police when it comes to the black
community
so Jasmine was convicted of attempted
lynching which is a law that was really
developed and created to protect black
people it was a law that was developed
to creative so that when white mobs were
literally taking pulling black people
out of police custody and trying to you
know who's trying to keep black people
safe and white people are pulling them
out of the mob as well said protect us
from white moms so that say that she was
lynching I'm somebody is not just ironic
it's dangerous and she was facing
anywhere from six months of jail time to
four years of state prison time and what
we saw today was I think you know that
the power of
the other and saying we're not gonna
allow this when I said allow for this
black woman to face prison time we think
she should have come home but we when
she gets home which will probably in
about 30 days we better believe that
usually back out in the streets
organizing BLM caste we heard a lot of
impassioned speakers this morning and
one of them the pastor I believe was
saying that this is the American
injustice system and he was speaking
about Rathbun at the Stanford University
student the white one the swimmer who
raped a woman and was received a lenient
six-month sentence and he was comparing
that to what Jasmine is facing and could
be facing Oh Timmy hung you know what I
will say is I'm an abolitionist I
believe that the current prison system
and the system is just sort of
perpetuating what we've had and so what
I do think we should be doing is calling
forth
I do think what we should be doing is
really challenging and pushing the
narrative of public safety a public
safety is not a badge and a gun Public
Safety is our ability to organize that
communities our ability to have access
to jobs I will say that what we do see
over and over again is black people
being convicted of both crimes we have
not done we see 2.3 million black
prisoners in the United States 1 million
of them are black people this is not a
coincidence and so it is our work as
abolitionists to undo systems and allies
that are in direct contradiction to
black people serving so I want to give a
chance if there's any audience members
since we are live right now with one of
the cofounders of black lives matter
patrisse cullors I think colors if you
want to ask her a question I don't know
and this is the conversation we're
hearing a lot around here right now and
that is you know as black lives matter
has risen to the level of national
prominence as it has right now and we're
hearing that Jasmine Richards people are
saying is that is the political prisoner
and we're hearing about activists being
targeted by the police do you as you
know active as you are at all feel
Target or that you're under some sort of
microscope the state oh yeah you know in
the first couple years of that
organizing my home was raided by LAPD
what year was that 2013 and 2014 and in
those raids
they came up right here you know made
claims at our home someone had come
taxed our home with a gun the second
claim was there was a person on the
loose community you know ran past our
home and not only did they raid our home
right afterwards it took pictures at my
home both inside and outside and this
hurt movement moment we know that was a
survey of no black lives matter
organizers protesters
we're being surveilled that's not a
secret it's been written about there's
been many articles that have sort of
highlighted how and why we're being
surveilled but surveillance is not a new
thing black people have been
surveillance at the moment we were
brought here surveillance is a way of
repressing us and you know when I first
started being surveilled I talked to my
one of my homeboys and he was like this
is a part of your life now
and it's not about trying to hide it so
every time there's any sort of display
of surveillance or repression I go to
social media and I put it out there and
I make sure that the community knows
what's happening to each community
member and that's what Jazmin has done I
think that's what this movement has done
it is made the invisible visible and I
think it's important you know as we're
talking about Jazmin Richards who likes
to be called Jazmin Abdullah is to talk
about what Keisha Wilson black woman who
was arrested and put in LAPD police
custody and then was found that was not
mother was not notified she had to call
a police station over and over again
eventually the coroner called her and
let her know that her daughter was
killed and she actually we know what
happened was I'm sorry I said killed she
committed suicide I put that in quotes
we know what happened it's a Los Angeles
case Sandra bland right
and so we are in this moment where la at
LAPD of the LA Sheriff's Department has
tortured killed brutalized harassed and
terrorized black people in this cabinet
and this case allows for us to have a
bunch of broader conversation thank you
so much you're just tuning in right now
I'm talking to pretty scholars who was
one of the three co-founders of black
lives matter in Pasadena outside of the
Superior Court where black lives matter
Pasadena activist Jasmine Richards just
received her sentence of 90 days so
folks out here are calling it a partial
victory
it's definitely calming down a bit maybe
there's a speaker over there I'm not
quite sure what's going on thank you so
much but she's photographer was was
there a question for ya so can we just
end our broadcast before any questions
show perfect so we have a question from
viewer lauren ashley and she wants to
know what can we do in our community to
help the movement there was a question
right before her where a latino viewer
was asking what can Latinos do so I
think it's sort of like a lot of the
audience members are wondering what they
can do to support I would I'll say to
black activist who's joined a local
chapter at this point we're at 40-plus
what I'll say to folks who have it you
don't have a chapter start a chapter and
we'll help assist you with that you can
find us at black lives matter at
gmail.com send us a direct email black
lives matter comm could set us a month
or a website and then what I'll say for
allies join or start ally support groups
there are dozens across the country or
allies of black people have come
together in support of black lives and
we've seen many examples whether that's
allies coming together to help with
logistics for actions to help bring
their their comrades together to get
signatures for Jasmine we had I think
over 20,000 API folks sign Asian Pacific
island we have 20,000 APM
Asian Pacific Islanders signed the
petition in support of jasmine being
freed and no jail time and so there are
ways in which allies can start getting
in formation to develop and create a
narrative that's for black lives
culturally but also concretely thank you
so much speaking of allies been hearing
honks all day about lines awarding
Jasmine Richards ikemen a wrap up right
now Tina took Korea here with shoddier
him Ian and my colleague Dario Medina
have been broadcasting outside of
Pasadena square house where Jessica
chose received her sentence thank you so
much for watching make sure you watch
the rest of our coverage on the aj+ all
day go vote primary